welcome back to the david pakman show i
am of course not david pakman david is
traveling to Las Vegas to the Ring of
Fire conference I was supposed to be
there Pat but life happens matter of
fact my flight is supposed to leave this
afternoon but I don't think I'm gonna be
able to get on that flight because the
family things and you know that's what
happens when you have kids you just have
to go with the flow but uh david has
asked me to sit in thank you David for
having me Pat thanks for hosting me
let's get to the news quid pro quo at
the FBI released documents connected
with their investigation of Hillary
Clinton and in that trove of documents
were included a document that indicated
that the State Department tried to
accentual II get something for something
to give up to give up seats give up
overseas positions for their FBI agents
for the FBI agents in exchange for the
declassification of a particular Clinton
email and so this is actually a mixed
story and it's actually a story of two
different accounts so the first account
is what I just described and I'll read
for you exactly the statement that came
from a unnamed FBI agent who said that
Patrick Kennedy who is a senior officer
in the state department offered the FBI
overseas additional overseas positions
in exchange for this declassification
and so the document actually stated this
and the name is redacted so allow me to
read it as is written redacted indicated
that he had been contacted by patrick
kennedy Under Secretary of State who had
asked his assistance in altering the
emails classification in exchange for a
quid pro quo red acted advised that in
exchange for marking the email
unclassified the department of state
would reciprocate by allowing the FBI to
place more agents in countries where
they were presently forbidding finally
at a subsequent meeting the State
Department regarding the classification
review of Clinton's materials where
Kennedy was presided someone asked
whether any of the emails in question
were
classified alright so that's a little
bit of background that's the first
account this is the account that
everyone has sunk their teeth into
because it literally uses the words quid
pro quo it literally suggests that the
State Department came in to ask for a
favor for Hillary Clinton in exchange
for a favor which is completely illegal
completely unethical this is the account
a second probably third hand account of
an agent who overheard something but
this is what everyone has sunk their
teeth into even Donald Trump I have a
video of Donald Trump where he's making
this out to be something that is huge
let's listen in to that video this is
very big and frankly it's unbelievable
what was just found out is that the
Department of Justice the State
Department and the FBI colluded got
together to make Hillary Clinton look
less guilty and look a lot better than
she looks this is one of the big
breaking stories of our time in my
opinion this shows corruption at the
highest level and we can't let it happen
as American citizens so let's see how
the press covers it the press likes not
to cover it because the best thing that
Hillary Clinton has going is the media
without the media she wouldn't even be
in this race that's enough this is cool
that's enough of that all right he's
going into his media diatribe everything
is the media's fault never mind the fact
that he benefited tremendously from the
media but I digress the point is he's
trying to sell this as the biggest news
in this election cycle and the media is
going to disregard it he's already sand
back in the situation here's the problem
there's an additional document that was
included in the same trove of documents
that were released that gave a second
account of this same incident pad where
it actually says that it was not the
State Department who offered the FBI
additional positions it was actually the
FBI who came to the State Department
saying if you do this for us will
consider will consider declassifying or
we will at least look at the email for
declassification so
it's it's it's an issue of somebody
offered somebody something and I hate to
be that vague but story one says that it
was a State Department meaning that it
was somebody for Hillary Clinton
somebody who wanted to look out for
Hillary Clinton offering the FBI
something in exchange for the
declassification account number two says
that it was actually the FBI who
proactively went to the State Department
and said well if you look at these
positions that we need will consider the
declassification either way it goes it
has the appearance of quid pro quo and
has made a lot of people very upset and
it is consistent with this idea that
Hillary email FBI investigation cover up
bad you know it's it's it's a mess and
it's no matter what the truth is in this
case it doesn't bode well for Hillary
Clinton what do you think it could
absolutely be concerning there's just no
evidence right now of a quid pro quo
because those slots that were offered to
the FBI I mean there's no reason to
believe that it was an exchange for for
anything in particular and of course
Trump has to try to play up this story
as the biggest breaking news of I'm
really because he's still recovering
from what happened to him about a week
ago that a story that was much easier
for people to wrap their head around and
a lot more people could relate to yeah
yeah I mean and that's the reality right
so simplicity is very important in in in
a media narrative but the fact of the
matter is we have two different accounts
and it really depends on what side of
the equation you fall on which account
you want to believe and there are a lot
of people who have gravitated to this is
clear evidence that the State Department
participated in a quid pro quo offering
the FBI is something in exchange but
it's not clear evidence of that uh if
anything it boils down to he said she
said kind of scenario that is very very
murky and that really truthfully the FBI
if there was something there one would
think right one would think the FBI
would have dug into that and file
charges based on that but you go down
one level lower and people say well
that's why the FBI can't be trusted
because they're in the tank for Hillary
Clinton my question for you pat is who's
not under control of
power in the force of Hillary Clinton in
the selection because it seems like the
FBI the Attorney General the media
everybody's underneath the influence of
Hillary Clinton it's all just one giant
conspiracy together elected I guess you
know a I will say this i do believe that
the media is trying to make a pendants
for their foolishness during the
primaries giving Donald Trump all of
this free media all this repast press so
now it does feel like they are in the
tank bra Hillary Clinton but if there's
ever any one to be opposed surely it's
Donald Trump Warby Parker is offering a
free five day home try-on to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses i personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / TDPS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / tdps it costs nothing